you guys I'm not that skinny I'm down to
119 pounds Kim Kardashian regrets how
she chose to celebrate her recent weight
loss my intention is never to offend
anyone and I really you know apologize
if I offended anyone the mom of three
appeared on the first episode of Ashley
Graham's podcast pretty big deal where
she opened up about the backlash she
received for probably announcing on
social media back in August that she
weighed 119 pounds I 100% completely
understand where people would be coming
from that felt that way the 37 year old
reality star came under fire after
sharing a series of videos of her being
praised by sisters Khloe and Kendall for
her slimmed down figure wait what was
that Kendall some fans felt they were
making light of eating disorders and Kim
admitted that she could see where her
critics were coming from I know people
that have serious eating disorders that
have been in and out of the hospital for
15 years
well close people I've experienced it
enough to have like known better you
know sometimes when you're you know I
was like with my sisters and we were
laughing and joking and I guess it's not
a dish you can get like carried away it
was insensitive despite the criticism
Kim says she's proud of her body which
she's worked hard on over the past year
I'd spent an entire year working out
with a bodybuilder literally six days a
week
lost 20 pounds and it hasn't been easy
it's been a year coming like people of
like like my mom even maybe a month ago
pulled me aside in the bathroom at a
meeting once and was like I need to talk
to you
and I was like oh my god what and she
pulls me signs like what are you doing
really like what is going on like how
are you losing this weight are you okay
and Kim says she plans to continue
showing off her fitness journey on
social media
I actually just feel like healthy and
strong and confident and so I want to
post it I want to show some fun
what heavy weights were doing like it's
not a joke
[Music]
[Applause]